as you progress in time fall two's
multiplayer you gain credits you use
credits to unlock abilities items and
Titans early seems straightforward
enough but as you gain credits you'll
notice they don't come as often as you
expect because some unlocks are pretty
expensive here lies the issue why bother
spending credits on an unlock if you're
just going to unlock it anyways at an
early pilot level luckily anything you
do unlock with them will still be
unlocked after a pilot level
regeneration so let's break it down
and pick some of the unlocks you might
want to strive for
so what should you unlock low profile is
clutch compared to the other perks and a
lot it allows you to silent rodeo a
Titan meaning no longer are you forced
to easily flee due to their electric
smoke you'll find yourself pulling
batteries dropping grenades much easier
not only that it also hides your jet
flares making you less noticeable
especially if you're an advocate of the
cloak the satchel charge is the last
ordnance you get and god it's powerful
with a very generous a OE pilot's be
exploded not only that you get to at the
ready so spread them out over bounty
hunt for cash stations they're expensive
220 credits but they'll get the job done
the smart pistol makes its return only
this time it's a boost
unfortunately this lock-on weapon
replaces your secondary but it's still
very effective against pilots and
mopping up grunt kills this boost will
set you back 125 credits the dice roll
boost is a good purchase not just
because it's the last to unlock but
allows you to try out everyone in the
lot ultimately it's a fun way to change
the game up but it's definitely an even
better way to get familiar with each
boost better helping you find your
favorite and or which boost is best in
any given situation so spend that
hundred 25 credits and spice things up
when it comes down to it do your best to
purchase unlocks for the purpose of
building loadouts specific to rolls for
instance if there's a pesky Titan
running havoc on your team
how about perfecting a Titan killer
loadout try combining satchel charges
cloak amped weapons with the anti Titan
Archer launcher consider amping up that
Archer on a Titan bounty and bounty hunt
when there's multiple people attacking
the same Titan launch that rocket and
steal that last hit those are just a few
of our notable unlocked picks if you
have some of your own do put them in the
comments section below
thanks for watching and for all things
Tyne fall stay tuned to game spot